the world of inside haunts you from
start to finish it's a world broken at
the hands of technological progress work
out and enslaved people shuffle
mindlessly through the streets overseers
dressed in masks and black clothes stand
guard waiting for one of the slaves to
fall out of line inside is the second
game from limbo developer play dead and
like limbo the gameplay is simple you
walk jump and grab objects in order to
solve puzzles and overcome obstacles
however inside is primarily about your
journey through a tyrannical
impenetrable and apocalyptic world over
the course of a few hours you descend
ever deeper into the heart of a
malicious and immense construct as you
try and discover what is hidden inside
and as you journey towards that secret
you experience stretches of quiet and
calm punctuated by flashes of absurd
violence or cruelty the game encourages
you to relish these often shocking or
brutal twists and they make you want to
know more and these moments remain vivid
in my memory even a few days after
completing the game a mindless sort of
figures followed me off a cliff only to
slam into the ground later a wispy
feminine creature tenaciously stalked me
through underwater regions I also led my
character to countless deaths that were
immediate and gruesome I loved the game
most during its quiet lulls when the
oppressive feeling of the world was most
apparent but I sometimes couldn't help
but laugh at the sheer ridiculousness of
these in-your-face moments as you move
through its world you're confronted with
puzzles that you must solve to progress
well most of these are fun that comes a
time when inside leans too heavily on
its puzzles to keep you engaged in these
moments I felt that my driving
motivation has shifted from exploring
the world to simply flipping the right
switch fortunately this issue evaporates
as the game enters its final act when
the world and puzzles again form a
cohesive bond inside is at its best when
it doesn't feel like you're doing
puzzles at all but rather avoiding
obstacles and finding paths through a
dangerous space and as inside nears its
conclusion the puzzles reinforce the
sense of exploration that defines the
rest of the game this feeling is
enhanced even more by insides visual and
sound design the game is gorgeous with
assemble but evocative art style defined
by muted colors and featureless figures
insides environments are richly detailed
and full of motion and secrets and this
style is complemented by insides often
breathtaking use of sound of music you
never hear voices but each setting has
its own unique noises music is used
sparingly but when it swells even minor
events like exiting a building became
points fixed in my memory
all of it the setting the sound and the
beautiful art builds to the discovery of
the secret of this compound but what I
found at the end almost ruined the
entire experience Sala T was thrown at
the window and I was left reeling unable
to process the turn but as time passed
those final moments grew on me I still
find the ending strange but upon playing
through inside a second time I found
endearing elements that fit with the
overall story more effectively than I
first thought
it's both humorous and also cathartic
releasing in one scene all of the
tension that have built up over the rest
of the game this is a beautiful in
haunting game and it's a worthy
follow-up to Limbo detailed environments
convey the bizarre world that you travel
through introspective moments are filled
with minimalistic sound design and
calculated touches of music and the
things that you must do to complete your
journey force you to confront the
realities of humanity freedom and
existence is enough motivation to return
to insides dystopia
you